Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters for another episode of Cutters Clinic Live,
our local podcast, and we have some very special guests today. We try to bring you the best
in the industry, and Will Reavick is the best in the industry. So, when we talk about oral health,
this is so important. When we talk about cancer and how so many cancers are tied
to oral issues and in oral gum disease that can spread, we see
thermography that you see just a line of, from a tooth to dead tooth, can be a line right
down to that breast cancer. It's so important to deal with oral health, and we do try to push people
to biological dentists and things, but this is stuff that you can do at home. We just started
to carry these products just a few months ago, and they are a huge hit. So, I'm going to read
your bio here, Will. Your wife is also a part of your little company that you have that's
gone away by leaps and mounds. Will and Susan Reavick are the founders of orawellness.com.
We're going to point you to their website. We sell your products on our website too, and we have a
special offer for our listeners today of their products. They're a holistic oral health brand.
That's really, really key because that has been a niche, I think, that you guys feel alone. There
are some other, you know, toothpaste cell that don't have fluoride and different things like that,
but that are really helping heal disease. You guys are really unique in that space.
That's why we wanted to carry your brand. What brought you to where you are right now?
Yeah. Well, thank you. First of all, thanks for having us. So, our journey started.
This is going back many, many years. Susan went to a new dentist. She'd been going to dentistry.
Her whole life went to a new dentist. We moved to a new town, and the dentist did what we now know
as a periodontal depth probe, which is going around and counting. And, you know, if you've ever
been in a dental chair in the dentist, or the hygienist is poking around your mouth and you're hearing
numbers like two, three, three, three, two, four, that they're measuring the pockets around the teeth
and the gum pockets. And so, Susan was getting this periodontal depth exam. She had a wisdom tooth
that she had. The dentist was not able to measure. It was greater than 10 millimeters. So, that's
almost half an inch, a little over half an inch. And it got very sober in the room, and the dentist
was like, ooh, okay, and went and got this pamphlet and handed it to my wife. And it's talking about
periodontal surgery and gum surgery and that whole route. My wife being very alternatively minded
rather than going that route. So, she woke up many years ago from the myth that just because somebody
in a position of power like a dentist or a doctor says to do something that it's the only route.
Right? So, she woke up from that and she's like, I'm going to go look into it myself and research
it herself went home, applied some at-home strategies and went back to that same dentist a year
later. And the same dentist measured again and was really confounded and was like, I must have
mismeasured last year because it says here that's a 10 plus millimeter pocket and it's only measuring
measuring three millimeters. She said, let me tell you what what I've done and the dentist more or
less said, I've got to go see another patient. And that put a fire in Susan. That this was outside
the understanding of conventional dentistry and still is honestly. And she was so frustrated that
the dentist wasn't willing to hear what she had done to create this dental miracle. And then in 2007
I think, you know, we basically said, okay, where's our home-based business that does no harm?
That really helps people that's going to be very fulfilling to do. And we kind of turned to each
other and said, maybe we should be talking about what you did in your mouth. So, 2010 we launched our
site. And now we're proud that we have happy customers in over 105 countries and growing.
The first product we came up with was our healthy mouth system, really, which was essentially the
system that Susan applied in her own mouth to effectively address advancing gum disease. Now we've
added more products to that as we've come up with new products, our healthy mouth blend. I'm sure we'll
talk products at some point and go into the detail and then shine a remineralizing tooth whitening powder
came along many years later, essentially, essentially as an answer to the question of wouldn't it be great
if we could offer something that didn't have fluoride in it that would help protect against future
decay and help address existing decay? Well, you look at the issues with gum disease in America,
just stick to our country here. And it's, it is like ubiquitous. I mean, it's just like,
whether you're going to get gum disease, that's basically it's become normalized.
So I want to separate and tease the differences between the word normal and the word common.
If you're over 30 years old, chances are greater than nine and a 10 that you have some active form of
gum disease. Okay. From a regulatory agency, it says 97% of every men of all the men, women and
children in the United States, 97% have some active form of active oral disease. Just because something
as common doesn't mean that it's normal. Everybody has tooth decay, right? Well, it's a disease, folks.
It's an active, it's a dental disease. No, it's not normal. It's very common. So what do you do about
it? We do provide a unique zone in the, you know, oral hygiene, oral health blogosphere and the
health and wellness sphere in that we're a, we're a holistic oral health company. And that is an
important consideration because, because our culture and clearly the industry has a tendency to
over compartmentalize and separate the mouth from the rest of the body. And so to be able to effectively
address tooth decay or gum disease, what we've found is it really requires a two-prong approach.
Not only do we approach it from an in-the-mouth angle, like there's things you can do in the mouth,
definitely to protect and reverse gum disease as well as tooth decay. But there's also a systemic
whole body approach. So we really look from a global and a local angles in order to provide this.
So from an in-the-mouth approach, oral hygiene plays an important role. The problem there is that
most of us don't revisit the subject of oral hygiene after the point of when we were like three
years old, when we learned to brush our teeth. You know, do you sign checks with a crayon? No, we
revisit subjects in order to improve our skills. And in this case, tooth brushing or flossing, in particular
flossing, plays a critical role in particular in the protection against and reversal of gum disease
as well as a whole host of systemic diseases that show up downstream from gum disease.
We have not victimized ourselves to the myth that what goes in the mouth stays in the mouth,
that I think most other products on the market have. Okay, most products on the market were formulated
by people who have victimized themselves to this myth that if you just spit, it's okay, it doesn't
go into the body. It's a total myth. It's not true. It's been proven. I mean, whether you're talking
about homeopathic medicines or a nitroglycerin-frangina, you put it under your tongue that's absorbed
through the mucosal tissue and it affects the whole body. There's a lot of products on the market
that are made with components that should not be going into the system because it undermines systemic
health ostensibly for the benefit of oral health. But I don't think that that's a long view on your
product formulation, your product formulation, at least a product formulation that we go through
and what we advocate and teach to our community is like, look, we don't care if you use our products,
our products are good. They've been born out of this holistic mindset, this holistic paradigm.
But if you wanted to discern whether your oral health products
were made from a holistic standpoint, you just have to answer a couple questions. Number one,
does it have any harm in the mouth? And number two, look downstream. What do the component
ingredients do downstream? And there's a lot of stuff on the market that is born again out of that
idea of the mind frame that if as long as I spit after I brush my teeth, it's okay. The product
formulators who made these products or the regulators who regulate these products being produced
are under the myth still. It's like they just believe something that we all learned as part of
the cultural story that we inherited. Sure. But it's been disproven in science. Absolutely.
So there's a disconnect. I mean, you're in the forefront of this. I'm sure with your work,
there's a disconnect between what the culture believes on one hand and what the science actually says
on the other hand, like what is the most important driver? Is profit the only driver? I think we all know
that if profit is the only driver, that can breed a lot of hideousness. Oh, it's definitely going to,
for sure. Yeah. Well, that's not your driver here making these products. That's definitely not.
This is a great world right here. Let's talk about this first. Yeah, shine. You know, wouldn't it be
great if we had a product that helped people to avoid future tooth decay and protect against existing
decay that didn't use a product like fluoride that has no business in being downstream of the mouth.
And the epiphany really came to us one day when I said, well, I mean, our teeth are bone, right?
It's really the only place in the body. It's a unique zone, if you think about it, where living bone
is exposed to the outside world. Wait, okay. So I put together it's living bone and it's a porous
surface. Like we feel our teeth and they feel really smooth like glass, but they're not. They're porous.
And so I said, well, what if we made the central component of this new product solution,
a really clean source of a tiny, tiny, tiny particle size of quality bone powder.
Well, let's go see if it exists and researched and we found something called MCHA microcrystalline
hydroxyapatite. That's a big sounding word. Let's break it down. Microcrystalline simply really tiny
particle size. Hydroxyapatite is the compound that our teeth are made of, that all bone are made of.
And hydroxyapatite is simply a molecule that is a certain number of parts of calcium with a certain
number of parts of phosphorus with a little hydroxide tight onto it. And we found low in the hole
that the research showed, wow, it's actually really impressive. I mean, it stands toe-to-toe if not
in some research studies a little bit better than fluoride as far as remineralization of the surface
of the teeth. And it's what our bones are actually made of, whereas when fluoride comes in contact with
the tooth surface, it actually makes what's called fluorapatite. It's not hydroxyapatite. The fluoride
ion goes in there and attaches to the superficial surface of the tooth and creates fluorapatite,
which some dentists have argued is actually harder. That's the marketing pitch. But it's also a
little more brittle. And so there's quite an undertow and undercurrent in the industry, questioning
whether or not fluoride causes the teeth to be a little bit more brittle and prone towards what
are called frocations or micro-cracks in the enamel. And just to anchor it there, Dr. Connors,
I'd like to tell a story of a lady, we got an email, we get testimonials, we're blessed that we get
testimonials every day. And this one lady just really kind of stands out for me. And she wrote
us and she said, oh, I finally figured out why I've had tooth decay throughout my life. I have an auto
immune condition that causes low saliva production, right? Makes sense. Yeah, low saliva production.
Saliva is the primary vehicle that our bodies remineralize our teeth through surface-wise,
through the teeth. She went to the dentist one day, dentist said, you have 11 new cavities.
Goodness. Like, oh my gosh, okay, well, so that freaked her out enough. She went home, did some research,
found us, bought our product, started using it. And I don't have the testimonial in front of me,
it was either three or six months later. She went back to the same dentist. And the hygienist first
saw her and said, where did you go to get the cavities filled? She's like, what are you talking about?
And obviously she's talking about shine here. Shine is the remineralizing component here of our
solutions, our product solutions that we offer. So all but one, the deepest, the deepest cavity
did not fully heal. The surface did remineralize, right? But the deepest cavity did not come back
all the way. But 10 out of the 11 cavities that the dentist had previously diagnosed said, we need to
get these filled, remineralized. And that's a feather in our cap, and I'm very proud of that. But
more importantly is, how does that person, how does that woman now feel? She's no longer a hopeless
victim. She has a very acute awareness, like, oh, wait, I can affect positive change in my oral health.
That's really what we're here to do is to provide hope. Not you can affect positive change
if you're willing to take a look and learn, which is why we do all of our outreach that we do,
write all sorts of articles, make educational videos, and provide the content that we do.
So the healthy mouth blend, so let me back up and talk about both shine and the healthy mouth blend,
because I think that we're really, this is part of the educational component of what we look to do.
The mouth, the whole oral zone, is a very, very diverse, complex environment. Despite what
the culture or the research says, the experts say, we know very little about it still.
Okay, we're learning all the time. And thankfully, we have a lot of good research going on to
explore different aspects. But suffice it to say that the way that we've approached this complex
zone of the mouth is to address it on a biological side, as well as on a chemical side.
So if you look at our two main products, there are two spirit products of the healthy mouth blend and shine,
the healthy mouth blend is looking to address it on the biological side. And shine is looking to address
it from the chemical side. So the healthy mouth blend is a blend of organic essential oils in an
organic carrier oil base. It's actually the only toothpaste alternative on the market. The
only toothpaste alternative on the market that is made from 100% certified organic ingredients,
which I think we already covered that and why we consider that to be important.
We address the biological component, because the bottom line is especially if we're talking about
gum disease, the bottom line is that gum disease is driven from a prevalence of pathogenic microbes
or disease causing thug bugs, as we call them, dominating the mouth. Now, one of the things that we
want to try to heal here in the global discussion, the global community, is this idea that has been very
prevalent for several decades now that I think listering really pushed out strongest,
back in the day, this idea that we got to kill all the bugs in the mouth, that idea.
Okay, we wouldn't be here if it weren't for bacteria. Yeah, the micro flora extends to every
orifice of your body. Exactly. And if we approach it like it's a war zone, we're going to harm ourselves,
what the healthy mouth blend has done is we dug into the research deeply and we found, for example,
oh, wow, manuka oil. Manuka, we're all familiar now in the alternative wellness
sphere of manuka honey. That's a honey that is from bees that harvest from the manuka plant.
This is not manuka honey, it's manuka oil is one of the ingredients in our healthy mouth blend,
shows in the literature that it is the most effective plant compound to stop a couple of key pathogens,
right? It effectively knocks down a pigeonge of Alice, which is one of the primary thug bugs and
really lead drivers of gum disease and periodontal disease. And it is also one of the few plant
compounds that can actually stop spirochetes, which you'll know from your line work, that spirochet
is an oral pathogen, but it's not just an oral pathogen. And it is nothing good to do in the body.
So the healthy mouth blend selectively looks to reduce thug bug populations while supporting the
biome in general and allowing the probiotic species to gain the upper hand again. In any biome,
you're going to have the majority, which is in the middle of that bell curve that are called commensals,
right? And they're basically neutral. And then you're going to have probiotics on one side and
pathogenic on the other side, right? So you got the ones that are very obviously for the health of the
host. And the other on the other side who are pretty arguably their thug bugs, they're pretty darn
obviously looking to destroy the host, maybe not so quickly because they rely on the host for health,
but they're definitely part of the decomposition process. Their reproduction will damage us.
There you go, exactly. And I mean, that leads us all into the whole, you know, how the correlation
between the healthy, between gum disease and why we made the healthy mouth blend and the whole host
of downstream diseases. I mean, just as a side tangent here, I just want to make sure that your audience
is on page with us. If a person has gum disease, let's just say advanced gum disease, which is called
periodontal disease, they are many times at greater risk for part disease, stroke, cancer, diabetes,
arthritis, low birth weight babies, Alzheimer's disease, recent research came out in 2019,
research paper came out. And the researcher was very courageous, I think, in making a statement.
You know, you read a lot of the research and they're always talking about the correlative.
Oh, there's an association between this and that, but they don't ever use the causation word.
Well, this researcher came out and said, we've been barking up the wrong tree on Alzheimer's.
This whole amyloid plaque by hypothesis is inaccurate. And this person is putting forward, this
researcher is putting forward in a fairly robust way and using the causal word saying that a periodontal
pathogens, oral pathogens are the cause of the destruction. And just like with the lipid hypothesis
with cardiovascular disease, this researcher is arguing that with the amyloid plaque hypothesis,
that it's kind of like blaming the firemen for the fire. Back to our healthy mouth blend,
we created the blend to help people manage their oral microflora better because see what happens
is when the thug bug populations build up and colonize enough, then the commensals
start to lean in the direction and they're like, yeah, come on, the pathogens are winning,
so we're going to emphasize that and it becomes a slippery slope. So we can just help cool off
the pathogens just to kind of, you know, it's called the ecological plaque hypothesis,
just like knock them back every once in a while, just cool them off, then the commensals can come back up
and if the probiotic species are strong, the commensals can actually lean in the direction of the
probiotics. And now you have a healthy balance in any biome you're talking about because we don't want
to remove the pathogens because everything has its place. We just don't want them to be run in the show.
We have to keep that in balance, exactly. Exactly. Which leads us really to one of our primary
strategies, if we go back to this idea of an in the mouth approach to addressing
improving one's oral health and navigating the path to greater oral health is to become a good
steward or a good conductor of the symphony of microbes in your mouth is what we're really doing.
So we have to understand where the thug bugs live, what can we do to disrupt and disorganize them?
We have to understand what to do to not disrupt our oral microbiome. What can we do to support
a healthy microbial community in there? What can we do to disrupt pathogens that are
in the wrong place that are colonizing down under the gum line because that's where gum disease
really gets going. So how is this used in conjunction with the show? The healthy mouth blend,
one of the benefits of using the healthy mouth blend is what's called adhesion inhibition.
Now what adhesion inhibition is essentially means that we're helping to create an environment on the
tooth where the biofilms, the plaque are thin, right? What the research very clearly shows is that as
plaque gets thicker, it becomes anaerobic and an anaerobic environment breeds a greater environment
for the pathogens. So one of the jobs as being a good conductor of the symphony microbes in our
mouths is to keep thin biofilms. One of the ways we do that is the healthy mouth blend provides
the benefit of adhesion inhibition. It makes it more difficult for these thug bugs or adhere to
the surface of our teeth. So using the healthy mouth blend first, there's a lot of ways you could
do it. You could brush with the healthy mouth blend in the morning and use shine at night. Or if you've
got something really going on, you could use them both at the same time. If you really want to
optimize it, my suggestion would be this. Learn how to use a bass toothbrush, right? Our bass toothbrushes
are the, we were the ones that really brought this idea back into the wellness. Your doctor,
bass was a, it was actually a parasitologist that came up with this bass brushing technique to help
disrupt and disorganize the thug bugs along the dumb line. So learn how to use a bass toothbrush and
using the bass brushing method. If you're not sure what I mean by that, go to our website.
There's a video, there's a couple of videos there that show you how to brush your teeth through
reduced gum disease. And take your bass toothbrush and put a couple of drops, two, three drops of the
healthy mouth blend on the brush and then bass brush, right? That's going to, that's going to thin biofilms
on your teeth. And then come back through and brush your teeth using shine. Okay, now the bass toothbrush
method is more focused along the gum line because that's really where the thug bugs associated with gum
and parodontal disease hang out. And then coming back with shine, well, shine is for addressing
tooth decay on the teeth. So let's, let's now brush on the teeth with shine. So if you really wanted to
optimize it, it would be a two step like that. Well, we want to get to our offer before we're at
the end of our time here. So these are my two favorite products. So this is where we're going to have
an offer on our store. He was using a code that, uh, that I'll tell you in just a second. So if you buy
this and this, you get another one of your great products that is a big hit by people who shop in our
store is the tongue cleaner. We won't get into that, but it's pretty self explanatory with these
wonderful directions on the back of it. We'll give you this for free. If you buy one each of these
using the code, uh, or a, or a wellness live for cutters clinic live, or a wellness live, use that code
in a shopping on our store, and you'll get that free. We're moving into an era in health care
that if you are not your own advocate, you are at a great disadvantage. So you need to, uh, become
knowledgeable. There's no more doctor well-be out there. That's really looking out for your,
your care. So you need to be your own advocate out there. So well, in closing anything,
the closing remarks that you just like to leave our listeners. I'd like to broaden it back out.
Again, because we are a holistic brand, and that's really the heart of what we're doing here,
and our mission is to help spread healthy smiles worldwide. If we consider that what goes in our mouths
is so important for our oral health and our whole being health, as, as a primary focus,
then let's just have a little bit of fun and contemplate what comes out of our mouths,
and the impact that that has. Because if we choose to speak words of poison, if we choose to speak
negatively to ourselves, if we choose to be the the Debbie Downer of our world, we're speaking
words of poison. And unfortunately, it's not just our cells and our organism that is negatively
impacted, but everybody else in your shot. So I encourage us all to put a couple doses of humility
in there, and remember that we're all in its together. And in this modern culture right now,
we're all stressed out to levels that humans are not well adapted to handle, in my opinion.
So be willing to laugh something off and give a word of praise, because I think that in the end
of the day, if we can be a blessing to ourselves and to the world around us,
then we're giving some type of contribution. That's a life-worth living. That's a day-worth living.
Well, thank you, Will. Say hello to your wife, Susan, for, and I thank her for having oral health
issues that brought you down this pathway. And we will have you back soon, because good assakes.
You are a wealth of knowledge to treat people. We got a vision further for sure. And thank you so
much for having us on, Dr. Carter. It's really an honor to be joining an arm with you to just
continue to raise the bar and help empower people to make wiser choices for themselves.
All right. Thank you, everybody. Again, we'll have the links to these products and how to get
your product for free when you get both of them. And we'll see you in the next episode of Pudders,
click it, bye.